depuis décembre et jusqu'à mars le
département des yvelines a remis en
place le dispositif laisse plus service
similaire à yvelines étudiants seniors
qui avait été créé pendant la canicule
de 2003 ce dispositif a pour objectif de
lutter contre l'isolément des personnes
âgées dans le cadre de la crise
sanitaire
le département a décidé d'aller plus
loin de renforcer ce dispositif est de
créer les plus donc pièces plus ses 300
étudiants et demandeurs d'emploi qui
rendent visite aux personnes âgées à
domicile leur passent des appels de
convivialité et les accompagne notamment
lors de promenades
ce service est en place dans plus de
trente commune yvelinoise ali mais par
exemple pauline étudiante en année de
césure a été embauché comme agent de
convivialité
j'aime bien l'idée de partage de
d'apprendre quelque chose des gens de me
sentir utile aussi et c'est vraiment ça
qui m'a donné envie de concrétiser les
choses et devient vraiment quasiment à
chaque visite on parle de la situation
actuelle qu'est-ce que ça engendre les
conséquences
et qu'est ce que ça peut leur faire
saison déjà lui-même la maladie yes plus
bénéficier à plus de 8000 seniors non
dépendants avec la crise sanitaire le
service est apprécié
ça me fait du bien parce que vu que je
que je fais tout seul et puis que j'ai
pas j'ai pas mes frères et soeurs qui
viennent je suis bien conscient d'avoir
des jeunes qui viennent de boivre on
parle on va se
on va se promener ça boit ça beau george
beaucoup d idées
le dispositif est gratuit pour les
personnes âgées et fait l'objet d'un
financement par le département
coût de l'opération 800000 euros cela
comprend notamment les salaires des 300
étudiants et demandeurs d'emploi